[Music]
this guy's super cool and you're gonna
love it okay
it's vaccination day it's vaccination
day
it's time for vaccine shot number two
i've got my mask with pikachu
so far so good is this an adult man this
is an adult man
look how like ladies
please if you've ever i need to know
please if you've ever [ __ ] a guy like
this before
i need you to contact us i need i need
to figure you out i need to figure out
how a woman can [ __ ] a guy like this
but i am running seven minutes late
i hope they'll jab me anyway i really
want look at his mask and the 92 man
this shot today
and then the pikachu mask over it now my
fear of covet can abate
i'll see actual real-life people it'll
be
totally strange you you stop seeing
people
and you know you can still get it right
yeah
wow am i so ready for this change
for the first time in forever i'll
emerge from my lockdown
what is this guy his deal mile high
brendan on tick tock
if this guy doesn't
i will be shocked for the first time in
forever i'll go catch pokemon downtown
look i'm not sure i'm not pretending to
be the coolest guy in the world or
anything
right i think me i don't think me and
royce have ever
tried to present ourselves as as cool
guys
i'm pretty cool i have a puppet see that
that's pretty cool holy chads have
puppets
thank you um oh i'm looking this up
this is some parent that does pokemon go
this guy is so
uncool and and so many people like this
exist now
my right wing friends might think i'm
crazy for colorado first
of all you don't have any right wing
friends
frankly i think that your claims of
having friends at all
frankly i think are suspect and uh
we should probably have to do an
evaluation i'd like you to give me a
list of all your friends
you're okay you're on the side of people
that likes making lists
and doing contact racing i want a list
of all your friends and i'd like to
contact
them without you there and ask them hey
are you friends with brendan and i want
to hear what they say when you're not
there
they're going to go oh god the guy who
sings all the time
the dude with a pikachu's mask ah he's
so annoying
i invited him to a party he said he
wouldn't go because of cover but he
[ __ ] insisted that he'd be there on
zoom
it was really awkward it's like wait are
you friends with that guy brandon oh the
weird guy with the mask it's always
singing frozen songs
no honestly like i felt bad from at work
one time because he's always sitting
alone and i just felt bad
one day and ate lunch at his table and
then he just
[ __ ] thinks i'm his friend now so i
posted one of his posts from the from
his instagram
and showing i'm gonna check
you better not be make me angry if
you're getting me back for the
construction gate construction worker
thing that
wasn't even my fault
let's see
riding with biden
there's there's just no
these people nobody has any
personality anymore do that like
we're all just we're all just like
[ __ ]
sacks of meat walking around with
[ __ ] graphic tees on
and you don't you're not allowed to have
any sort of a personality
anymore there's a new one the only thing
you're a lot like
it's like it's like a shitty character
creation engine
where you think wow we're gonna have
such cool
attributes you can make for your
character and then really
you grow up and it's just a matter of
what graphic tees you're gonna wear
and uh what what kind of [ __ ]
whether you like marvel or dc and and
mostly politics like there's no more
nobody has a personality anymore
my vaccine is one billion percent
effective that's a really funny thing
yeah put out there remember remember
remember
austin powers these people are broken
right
yeah of course they're just mentally
they're not only like i used to want to
hate guys like this and i legitimately
like
i feel bad for that guy because like he
wasn't born that way
and like i don't it was probably the
vaccine
it was probably normal before that but
it's like what what
ah so many series of bad decisions led
to him being who he is today and
it's like ah it just makes me sick this
is what his profile looks like
why are you why are you doing this by
the way fiona chad says you shouldn't
i know but i just i do i i
feel bad for some of these people
because like think about it
you can't really give me a [ __ ] solid
reason as to why you are the way you are
and they are the way they are i mean
yeah we've made decisions that got us
here
and things that our parents taught us
and there's there are
factors that are involved um uh
nature and nurture and all that but that
guy ended up there and i ended up here
and it's like
when you see just like what one
chromosome will do to make
think about how easily you could have
been that guy like yeah i feel bad for
people sometimes